ABCs of AI s is for security AI has the
potential to drastically improve how we
identify address and reduce cyber
security risks generative Ai and
Foundation models can be used in cyber
security to overcome challenges in
threat monitoring architecting systems
and tools and even Talent shortages for
example a foundation model trained and
fine-tuned for security can help
identify threats at scale in real time
automate the management of cyber
security systems and tools and can even
make SE Ops more accessible by pairing
the workforce with a foundation model
that's trained in a variety of security
related data sets and threat
intelligence like security AI workbench
check out some other cool stuff related
to Security in this longer video or you
can go to cloud.google.com
security slai and we'll see you for the
next episode of